mr. president people want to know what
is your favorite book well the Bible is
is the book that shaped me and moved me
the most but in addition to that Toni
Morrison's Song of Solomon might be one
of my favorite books it's just a
beautiful beautiful book and I've gotten
a chance to know Toni Morrison during
the course of this campaign and she's
just as elegant and wise and thoughtful
as you'd want her to be you know it's
always nice when you meet somebody and
they turn out to be like you want them
to be she's she's just a spectacular
writer and a spectacular woman
Shakespeare's tragedies whether it's
Hamlet or Lear you know there's so much
in each of those tragedies I mean you
can you can read that once a year and
each year there's something new there's
something you didn't notice there's some
insight into the human dilemma it's it's
powerful stuff thank you guys so much
for watching I'd love to know if you've
read the books that President Obama
recommends but you thought of them leave
it in the comments below also if you
like this series and wanted to continue
where we learned from people who've had
success with their favorite books are
leave it in the comments and maybe we'll
keep doing it thank you guys for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon